the beset Oh brothers never imagined
things would get this bad they urgently
need money for their window frame shop
they're losing orders many already done
have yet to be paid if they ever will be
and the banks won't grant them any more
loans they don't know where to turn
the cornerstone of their operation is
this milling machine it costs nearly 1
million euros the monthly installments
are six thousand almost everything they
make they've already had to let half
their employees go wider than a 30
Normandy the banks only look at the
figures they don't see the people who
produce things they don't see the
history of the business we're just
numbers to them and if the numbers don't
add up they say they can't help us
Lombardi is the heartland of Italy's
industry and manufacturing the small
town of Len Yano is proud of its history
Barbarossa's Imperial forces were
stopped here more than 800 years ago
many small and mid-sized companies have
settled and prospered in the region but
that was before the crisis hit Paolo
Farah grew up in Lanyon oh now as
president of the local trade association
he sees the steadily growing fear and
desperation among its inhabitants on you
Jordan off or dealing business owners
come to me with tears in their eyes and
say they have to pay the rent the goods
and their taxes and they don't know
where it's all going to come from the
banks aren't giving any loans anymore
can they do kosovo Paolo ferry tries to
help out businesses with guarantees from
the trade association but that doesn't
impress the banks which seem to have
their own agenda and they're not willing
to give any clue to the cameras what it
might be
not even businesses that are doing well
are able to get loans these days at the
seal Tech's textile factory inland Yano
Danielle Etsy me and ten employees so
curtains they have enough orders even
some from abroad and they'd like to
expand but they can't borrow the capital
they need to invest now they're barely
treading water instead of moving ahead
and hiring impreza bukata if the
business owners are blocked and business
is stagnated you can't make any
investments we keep at it but the
difficulties are mounting and the bank's
push you to the point where you have to
close up shop only a few years ago the
business owners say Italy's banks were
handing out loans right and left now
they're penny pinching is ruining the
economy then I owned a we have a saying
the banks will give you an umbrella when
the sun is shining and take it away
again when it's raining the banks ought
to act like banks again and show more
confidence in businesses during times of
crisis ivy a few feeders and an aphasic
the three brothers and their window
frame shop could use a bit of confidence
time and working capital are swiftly
running out